[Music]
kids are funny and sometimes they
unintentionally reveal a lot of things
about their parents and their home life
check out these drawings to find out
whose mother likes to pass gas and whose
babysitter is in huge trouble stay tuned
to see the creepy drawing that should be
taken to the police give this video a
thumbs up and hit that subscribe button
to never miss another video again now
let's check out 20 most hilarious kid
drawings that will make you laugh when I
grow up we all wanted to have a
different job when we were kids some
wanted to become singers doctors or vets
and others chose a profession that was
similar to what our parents were doing
this kid definitely wanted to be like
their mommy but their join makes us
wonder what the mommy is actually doing
what do you think the poll the money in
hand and obviously very happy faces
issue professional pole dancer or does
she belong to the oldest profession in
the world we hope it's the first one
otherwise this kid has seen far too many
inappropriate things in their life what
did you want to be when you were a kid
let us know in the comments daddy loves
sugar sometimes children's drawings
reveal far too much about their lives
and most importantly the lives of their
parents we're pretty sure everyone knows
what this image is supposed to represent
according to this child his dad really
loves sugar on one hand we hope this is
actually sugar and his dad just wanted
to make an inappropriate joke but on the
other we hope the kid is living in a
safe household although judging by the
fact that this kid wrote that his dad
actually eats sugar with his nose it's
safe to say that the kid has to witness
a lot more things than they should we do
hope this school had a little chat with
the dad 100 years old sometimes kids
provide realistic answers that can
really make us think this child is
definitely one of those kids that
doesn't want to sugarcoat anything
including death some of us like to think
will live forever but not this child
when Graham got asked to draw what he'll
be doing when he was 100 years old
Graham didn't hold back he drew a bunch
of tombstone
and wrote that he'll be breaking out of
his tomb to be fair with the popularity
of zombies at an all-time high
you never know what will happen in 100
years maybe they'll find a way to
actually resurrect people Graham
definitely think so
Buzz Lightyear if you love pies this
drawing will make me think of them in a
completely different way and we
apologize in advance and if you love Toy
Story you'll never be able to unsee this
Buzz Lightyear is definitely everyone's
favorite Space Ranger and a favorite
character from Toy Story how could you
not love his happy-go-lucky personality
this child did a pretty impressive
drawing of Buzz in action but were more
entertained by his attempts at trying to
spell I come in peace it'll definitely
give us a few giggles but it also makes
us wonder if Buzz has any secret
fetishes we'll never know about t is for
sometimes the kids drawings aren't that
bad it's the comments that make us laugh
out loud a simple spelling mistake can
change the meaning of the entire
sentence that's exactly what happens
with this child we have a feeling they
are practicing the alphabet but have
chosen a very difficult word to spell to
add to the confusion the kid also drew a
woman and didn't think to highlight the
object they were talking about
thanks to their teacher it's clear the
same meant that t is for tights and not
something entirely different and totally
inappropriate of course they weren't
wrong either away Beach we've all heard
the play on words that lights the beach
referring to the actual beach side
instead of the inappropriate word once
again the kids hilarious way of spelling
things made this situation a lot funnier
than it should be not a lot of kids are
able to make their drawings go viral at
such a young age but Cameron totally
nailed this Cameron loves the beach but
unfortunately she's not the best at
spelling it admit it you'd giggle at
this unfortunate misfit
it can happen to anyone we're sure
Cameron will look back on this moment
and laugh when she's older and we hope
she'll still love the beach scissors not
everyone is an artist and it takes a
while for people to actually be able to
recreate real-life objects on paper this
unfortunate drawing of scissors
is a clear example of how sometimes
things just get a little bit out of hand
be honest would you know that these were
supposed to be scissors if it wasn't for
the description underneath we definitely
struggle one thing's for certain we want
to know who this child's art teacher is
and why this child thinks scissors look
like this in the first place
don't worry kid you'll get better at
join and according to our next drawings
you're not the only one keep practicing
star wars kids have a wild imagination
and a very clever mind this kid seems to
love food just as much as they love Star
Wars and the results are absolutely
hilarious we are dying over these names
and illustrations
there's Darth bacon boba pancake Luke
egg Walker toast solo sausage trooper
and hash Baca definitely sounds better
than the original Star Wars and Darth
bacon would be the perfect villain can
Luke egg Walker take him on or will it
all get too tempting and end in a huge
feast this has to be one of our favorite
illustrations well done to the kid that
drew this but it's not over yet the next
kid seems to really have it in for the
world's most popular reality TV family
the Kardashians it sounds like this kid
is stuck watching Keeping Up with the
Kardashians for more than they want so
they decided to rewrite their own ending
to the show in their version the Hulk
comes to smash the Kardashians one of
them gets excited over a tan while the
other says she just got married for 72
whole minutes The Hulk doesn't seem to
care at all and he smashes the
Kardashians to end this drama and that's
the end of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians seems like a totally
believable story and we'd love to see a
complete fan fiction to this one what do
you think yeah your name for the
Kardashians the lighthouse if there's
one thing we've learned today it's that
not all kids are amazing artists and
sometimes their image can represent
something totally inappropriate like
this drawing that's supposed to
represent a lighthouse do you see it the
red streaks are supposed to represent
the light but to be honest we're very
confused
shape it definitely reminds us of
something totally inappropriate and if
this wasn't a kid drawing do you
honestly think the person who drew this
just has a sick sense of humor it's not
the first and definitely not the last
time kids unintentionally drew totally
inappropriate objects mom being around
family members all the time makes us see
things not a lot of people do but the
way this child drew their mom makes us
wonder just how much time does she spend
passing gas and whether this is such a
common occurrence it's all she's known
for judging by this picture
farting seems to be a pretty common
thing for this mom after all you know
what they say it's really not healthy to
hold it all in and at least this mom
looks pretty happy compared to some of
the other parents we showed you today or
our next babysitter who's just very
unlucky babysitter some babysitter's are
so nice that we remember them even as
adults others aren't so lucky
babysitter's sometimes end up with kids
that make their lives
totally miserable and it looks like
Valerie ended up babysitting one of
those kids Valerie got an unfortunate
picture made by the child she was
babysitting it reads dear Valerie get
out of my life and underneath it there's
a drawing that could easily scare just
about anyone it looks like this child
wants to take an axe and behead Valerie
what did she ever do to this kids to
deserve such a picture
we're pretty sure Valerie never ever
babysat that child again keep yourself
clean we mentioned before that kids
drawings can sometimes turn into
something totally inappropriate by a
complete accident
it's hard to draw things in a realistic
way and some even struggle with drawing
as adults so we can't blame this child
for just wanting to educate people on
washing their hands with soap and warm
water to get rid of the germs but the
way they drew the pipe reminds us of a
different kind of pipe that's totally
inappropriate for little kids to draw in
the first place you have to admit the
weird drawing and the hands make this
picture totally hilarious and don't
forget to wash your hands with soap and
water
taking fights seriously but Valerie the
babysitter wasn't the only one
I got a violent picture from a child
some kids take fights very seriously
after a fight with her dad this child
gave him a picture that's pretty
disturbing she seems to want to cut off
her dad's neck with a knife and she
looks pretty happy doing it while the
dad is obviously trying to make it even
more creepy she wrote this is going to
happen to you we just hope this dad had
a long talk with his daughter that she
should never even think about these
things just because of a silly fight
poor dad ducks
we're telling you kids have a wild
imagination
we're not sure what made this child draw
this but it's pretty hilarious and we
can totally imagine ducks doing this
even though the majority of domestic
ducks probably aren't able to fly this
high but we're giving props to this kids
amazing imagination did you notice that
all the ducks are also cross-eyed we
have no idea why they are cross-eyed or
why they are passing gas to fly in the
first place but we're absolutely loving
this concept big thumbs up for creative
imagination and awesome drawing skills
can we borrow this kids minds and get
some inspiration for our videos mom
we've learned that the best way to see
the lifestyle of the parents is through
kids drawings just ask them to draw what
their parents are doing and what their
favorite thing to do is and you'll end
up with tons of surprises like this
picture that shows two different sides
of this person's mom who definitely
isn't a morning person on the left you
get to see what mom looks like in the
morning uncombed hair a zombie look and
messy hands make it seem like this mom
is having a hard time but the right
picture shows us that this mom is
totally living for her nights out go dad
we also have a few questions about this
dad's lifestyle that seems to be a bit
too much for a child to listen to
according to this description the child
can hear dad wrestling in his bedroom
and he can tell he's winning because of
the sounds she makes totally
inappropriate for any child to ever
witness but what makes it even worse is
the picture that goes along with it this
kid seems to be pretty happy and is
purging his dad and we won't even
mention the illustrative noises that
seemed to be coming out of his dad's
bedroom it's time for the school to have
a talk with his dad and his wrestling
best chef ever the coincidence of this
picture makes it one of the most
hilarious things we have ever seen the
drawing itself makes dad look like he's
a painter or something else that's
totally inappropriate but the caption
doesn't help his situation at all we're
pretty sure this child meant to say that
their dad is the best cook ever
but the misspelling of the word cook and
the strange hat on a dead head make it
seem like they meant something totally
different
we'll never get over kids and their
hilarious drawing skills that can turn a
simple scene into something way too
inappropriate for words there's a demon
sometimes kids can see or share things
that adults can't and a lot of the times
they're pretty creepy there are multiple
stories of kids witnessing something
supernatural out there but this one
makes us one to ask even more questions
this kid drew a picture of him and his
mom and dad and their cat underneath it
he wrote that he had a fun time with
them and that even the demon left them
alone that time he even drew a picture
of the demon which to be honest he looks
pretty scary
we definitely have questions about what
kind of demons does this child see when
he's spending time with his family go to
sleep but the award for the picture that
would give any parents a heart attack
goes to this child we're not sure
whether this image is real but if so we
hope the parents checked up on Timmy to
see how he's actually doing and keep him
away from this kid in the caption this
child wrote that mom will be so proud
that he got Timmy to sleep
but his drawing of how he actually put
to me the sleep raises even more
questions we really hope that Timmy's
actually okay and that this was all just
a big joke what's the best drawing
you've ever created let us know in the
comments
and that's it for our video for more
videos like this one check out 20
funniest kid test answers see you next
time
[Music]